Thanks everybody.
Thanks for being here.
Uh,
today I am talking about the ethical
oos ethical operating system,
uh,
or if you want to call it a guide to
anticipating the future impact of today's
technology. We'll talk a lot
more about what that means. Uh,
but for now,
let's just say that this talk is about
how not to regret the things that you
will build. Um, and the ways,
the tools, the foresight,
the frameworks that we can bring to the
process of developing new technologies
to ensure that we have
in mind from the outset,
the user,
the societies,
the communities that will be impacted by
the products that we actually build and
ultimately ship.
So as already mentioned,
I am yours. If, um, there's my
Twitter handle, if you want to tag me.
Um,
I have been doing this work and thinking
pretty deeply about how we build more
innovative, yet responsible products
for a while at Omidyar network. Uh,
and let me tell you a little bit about
what Omidyar network is and what the tech
and society solutions lab is.
To give a little context.
So this is my boss's boss's
boss. Uh, Pierre Omidyar,
who was the founder of Ebay and
from the earliest days at Ebay,
Pierre had a vision for tech as a great
distributor of opportunity in the world
and a great tool for empowering people to,
uh,
really lift themselves up,
right?
If you think about Ebay as a marketplace
where everyone could be a buyer and a
seller,
it was at the core a project
in that idea of empowerment.
And so when Ebay IPO,
Pierre took much of the
wealthy accumulated and
rolled it into Omidyar network
as well as our sister institutions,
uh,
to have social impact through
four and nonprofit investments.
And so for the last 14 or so years,
Omidyar network has been
making investments globally
in things like financial
inclusion, citizen engagement, education,
property rights, digital identity,
a whole range of things with this central
thesis of empowering people around the
world. Uh, in about 2016 or so, we,
like everyone else kind of ran
into a brick wall of an awakening.
That sort of happened,
I think for a lot of us around Brexit
and for many of us around the 2016
elections.
And some of what happened through the
2016 elections in terms of manipulation of
our democratic process,
et cetera.
When we all kind of collectively
woke up and said, oh, wait a second,
that tech that we thought was just
going to solve all the world's problems
actually has some pretty deep,
uh,
problems and challenges that we
actually need to address as well.
And so we had a mid network
beyond thinking about, okay,
we've had this techno
optimism for so long.
How do we actually ensure that the tech
that we are developing is actually good
for people? So not just thinking about
tech in its application for good,
but actually tech that
at its core is good.
And so we stood up the tech and
society solutions lab, which Eh,
aims at our core to help
technologists to mitigate, to prevent,
to correct the downsides of technology,
to ensure that it can live up to its
potential as that positive force for good
in the world.
And so we're doing that by cocreating
and supporting the creation of solutions
to advance these goals. There's been
a lot of talk about the problems.
We'll do a little bit of
that, uh, in a few minutes.
But at the core we're focused on what
are the solutions to those challenges.
And Ethical Oos is one of the tools that
we've built in order to address some of
those challenges. So what
brings us here today, um,
there's been a lot of talk
about the challenges that
tech has created for people
and these are just a few
that are appearing, uh,
challenges around transparency
and pass pass city, uh,
about how decisions are made around
tech and what decisions are being made
beyond our control and
beyond our understanding how
algorithms are developed and
the biases that they
might be perpetuating,
how privacy and security are
built or not in the products,
how text mono culture might be
perpetuating many of these things, uh,
ranging all the way down to environmental
impacts of the tech we're building and
rising social inequality
and economic inequality.
It's a whole range of issues that bring
us to the table and thinking about how
we build more responsible products.
So here's an analogy I like to use,
and this is with all credit to the folks
at Santa Clara University in their tech
ethics practice. But
foresight issues, if you will,
ethical issues are like birds first.
They're everywhere.
Okay? Some are ordinary, some rares, some
are big, some are small, some are local,
some are exotic, some are ubiquitous,
but there are birds everywhere.
But it's actually really
easy to go through life
surrounded by them and not see
them at all.
Right?
They just sort of are in the background
and if you're not paying attention,
you won't even notice the birds.
Getting good at seeing them is
a skill only built by practice.
And practice makes us finding them
easier and actually more rewarding.
So when your practice and seeing the
birds, it becomes an a daily ritual.
It becomes part of what you do as
you navigate through the world.
It becomes that much more rewarding.
Skilled watchers learn how to see them
and where and when they're most likely to
turn up. Right? So when you are
a birdwatcher, it becomes, oh,
I know that if I had to this forest,
I'm likely to see these types of birds.
Right?
And actually it,
certain types are found more
in some landscapes than others.
Some are not found anywhere at all,
right?
You can sort of predict with some degree
of certainty about where those birds
may appear, it's actually
easier to spot them with help.
So if you have a birdwatching
buddy next to you,
you're doubling your capacity to
actually spot the birds on the landscape.
And finally, you may need special
lenses actually to see those birds.
Your own eyes may limit your ability to
actually spot the bird on the horizon.
And so a special lens like ethical Oos
or any other framework helps you to spot
them. So, uh,
if you just replace the word birds with
ethical issues or foresight issues,
I think you understand how this
analogy actually plays out.
And so we've built the ethical alas to
actually aid and just doing this very
thing. And we built it alongside
the Institute for the Future, uh,
and nonprofit group based in Palo Alto
who think deeply about these issues of
foresight, how we think
about consequences, future
technologies, et cetera.
And together we decided that if
you can't predict the future,
you're in the wrong business.
Just kidding. But at the core,
one of the things that we are interested
in doing is thinking about those
consequences of technology.
And when we think about the
consequences of human systems, uh,
that are sped up, amplified or
disrupted by those technologies.
So we know actually that no one can
predict what tomorrow will bring.
Uh,
and so until we get a crystal ball app,
the best we can hope to do is to build
the muscle of anticipating longterm
social impacts, which is essentially
what ethical [inaudible] has meant to do.
And so it's actually not necessary
that we predict the future.
It's just that we get better at
practicing the skill of birdwatching.
Right?
Which I will now introduce you to.
So I think a low ass is designed to
help makers of tech, product managers,
engineers and others get in front
of problems before they happen.
So it's actually been designed to
facilitate better product development,
faster deployment,
and more impactful innovation.
So we have this thing as technologists,
right?
Where we imagine that
the products we build,
we'll solve all the world's problems and
actually it will all change the world
for the better. And that to a
large extent is true, right? Um,
but it is also useful at times to
think of the glass as half empty.
If we're always seeing the glass
as half full or entirely full,
we will not be spotting the
risks before they happen.
So here are the three questions really
that this is designed to ask the,
there are many more embedded.
Um,
if the technology you're building right
now will someday be used in unexpected
ways, what can you do
to prepare for it? Uh,
what new categories of risks
should you be paying attention to?
And lastly, what choices can you make
that would actively safeguard users,
communities, society, and your
company? In this case, Google.
But any company from future risks.
So we built three different tools in the
ethical s I'll introduce you to each of
those tools as a way of exercising
this foresight muscle. Um,
and the first is a set of scenarios to
consider that just sort of start pumping
the juices. Think of it as a
warmup for your run, right?
This is just getting the blood flowing,
thinking about the potential risks of
technologies with some specific city,
excuse me, scenarios. So you know,
some questions to ask about each
of these scenarios is, you know,
what's your greatest worry
when you imagine this future,
how might different users be
affected differently by this future?
What actions would you take if you could
foresee those impacts down the road and
what could we together be
doing differently to prepare
for that risky future?
So this is a little black mirror tree.
Apologies for that.
In fact,
some of the scenarios that we built in
the ethical s have now been played out on
episodes of black mirror as
well as actually in the world.
We've seen some of them. So we built
a scenario around smart toilets,
which we actually couldn't have imagined
would be demoed at ces this past
January.
Um,
so it's the muscle of predicting some of
these things is actually really useful
to exercise. And here are a
couple of the scenarios we belt.
So are you ready for a future where
conversation bots have been trained to
imitate specific people?
So not just people in general and uh,
you know, any, a generic user or
a customer service representative,
but your grandmother or a celebrity using
datasets collected from public social
media posts. And those bots are deployed
across networks, email and text messages,
and super targeted super
personalized propaganda campaigns.
And they are,
as a result,
highly effective in changing
opinions and driving action. Right?
As these messages appear to be
from your family and friends,
what are you worried about?
What can we do to prevent this future?
How would people be disproportionately
impacted by a future in which this
happens?
You know,
in response to growing concerns over
tech addiction and anticipating governant
government regulation
as a possible future.
Several popular social media and game
companies decide to voluntarily enforced
time limits. Sounds like
a good idea, right? Um,
so adults might be limited
to two hours a day.
Kids might be limited to one hour a day.
And actually whether a platform is limited
or unlimited becomes a major selling
point for them.
You can imagine that world in which an
unlimited platform is much hotter as a
consumer good and people,
but some people at the same time prefer
having hard limits that PR that prevent
them from becoming addicted.
So again,
who is affected? There was actually
just an article in the New York Times,
I think last week about how in some
measure personal human interaction is
becoming a luxury good
a as those with lesser,
um, opportunities are more
engaged with screens, right?
So you can think about the disparate
impacts of this kind of a future fortune
500 re human resource
departments subscribed to a
smart employer service that
evaluates a person's suitability for your
culture and the stress associated with
that culture.
Using social media posts.
We already kind of do this,
uh, people trolling, Facebook,
Instagram, etc. To understand
who the potential employee is.
But you can imagine being this being
automated through artificial intelligence.
So algorithms can actually
identify individuals suffering
from mental illness or
depression, right? You could, the service
could actually develop symptoms of,
you could predict the development of
mental illness in the future based on
trends in the individual's postings.
Again,
you can imagine the impacts that that
would have on workforce on the future of
work, on hiring, on, and again, disparate
impacts on different groups of people.
A major social network company in the
future could purchase a top US bank and
become a first of its kind
social credit provider.
And it could base mortgage loans,
loan approvals,
credit access on deep data collected
from its social platform and could take
into consideration credit histories of
your friends and family as well as the
locations you've visited.
So imagine if you've visited a bar or a
legal marijuana dispensary figuring into
your social credit and the credit
that your bank might provide.
And it could actually also do semantic
analysis of your messages and photos to
actually decide whether you are generally
happy, angry, anxious, or depressed.
Figure that into whether
you get alone as well.
25% of online orders
are delivered by drone.
Sounds great,
comes right to your door.
But actually these drones are fitted with
cameras and sensors to collect data as
they fly over neighborhoods,
which actually provides,
right the drone company with additional
revenue for the shippers and merchants
in some individuals can actually opt
out for free, unlimited drone delivery,
uh,
by paying.
And they consent to the collection of
their data by doing that for the drones
that fly over.
But actually neighborhoods where the
drone delivery is legally permitted or
subject to the same data
collection activities,
even though not all of their residents
or households have explicitly consented.
And again, who is impacted? What
could we do to prevent this future?
If you think about it?
So one of the tools that you can use
to think about these impacts of a tech
product you're building before it happens,
it's called a futures wheel.
And if you take one thing from this talk,
I hope you take a lot of
things from the stock.
But if you take one thing from this talk,
the future's wheel is an incredibly
powerful tool for thinking these things
through. So put at the center,
your product, your change,
the idea you have.
Let's go to the last example.
Drone delivery of orders,
right?
A of online orders and spin out from that,
the consequences that might happen first
order consequences and then from each
of those first order
consequences. Think, okay,
and then what happens and then what
happens and then what happens from each of
these nodes on the futures.
We all,
so I'll give you just two quick examples
that I easily pulled actually from the
web by just googling futures. We all, um,
so the first is that there
are increased choices, right?
For renewable energy,
which sounds like an incredibly
positive development in the world,
right? Um, and we would
all likely think, well,
increased choices for renewable energy
is positive as a positive development.
So put that in the center of your futures.
We all,
and then spin out the first order
consequences of that. Right?
So you can imagine new companies emerging
in the energy marketplace, oil prices,
falling, monopolies being dismantled and
technologies being developed, you know,
based on geography and politics.
Again,
those all sound really positive
as first order consequences.
But when you spend some of those out,
you actually get to some
negative consequences. Now
on the second order, right?
So if oil prices fall,
jobs can disappear in the oil industry
and some poor countries can actually
become oil dependent, right?
Because oil is now cheaper.
So poor countries can access more oil
rather than renewables and they become oil
dependent as a result. Right? Um,
and actually you can imagine also on
loss of monopolies that actually war and
poverty could result for countries who
are not competitive in the marketplace,
right? So it takes this tool
of figuring out first order,
second order,
third order consequences in order
sometimes to see the negative impacts.
So again, we imagine renewables
good first order good.
When we get to second and third,
or oftentimes on the horizon,
you can see potential risks out ahead.
Here's another one.
I'm sorry if this is illegible again,
I just pulled it from the web.
Uh,
at the center of this futures wheel is
open source technology and generally,
you know, popular sentiment is that
open source technology is a net good,
it's positive development,
et cetera.
I'm not going to go through
this entire futures wheel,
but I just wanted to highlight a few
things further out on the degrees of
consequences and impacts here.
So if you get out far enough,
you have you know,
untraceable terrorism,
you have companies failing,
you have, you know,
a loss of jobs, you have lack of
attribution of product development,
you have some potential negative impacts
from open source technology that might
not have been expected right
at the outset. So again,
just a useful tool and starting
to think through future impacts.
Second tool,
risk scanning.
So we created eight risk zones to look
at when thinking about your products.
And I'm going to go through
each of these in some detail,
but just to highlight them
here. Risks Zone one, truth,
disinformation and propaganda to
addiction and the dopamine economy. Three,
economic and asset inequalities for
machine ethics. And algorithmic bias.
Five, the surveillance state. Sixth,
data control and monetization.
Seven,
implicit trust in user understanding
an eight hateful and criminal actors.
So by dividing into
these eight risk zones,
we could sort of identify spaces
where hard to anticipate and unwelcome
consequences are most likely to emerge,
say over the next 10 years.
Now I want to stipulate,
we did not include every area
where things might go wrong, right?
So you'll notice here environmental
impacts are not included. Again,
this was meant to be the intersection
of both on hard to anticipate and
unwelcome.
We actually know that environmental
impacts are likely to come.
So that's not hard to anticipate.
These risks.
Villains are really just meant to
represent those hard anticipate areas.
So let's talk about risks on one truth,
dif information and propaganda.
And in this future,
shared facts are under attack.
And the primary mode of attacking,
uh,
today,
these kinds of shared
facts has been fake video,
right? So this is a signal
that we see on the landscape,
but that says this is a
potential risk zone in the,
in the near term,
right?
So everything from fake news to bots
that spread propaganda and deep fakes,
which are highly convincing video
that's algorithmically altered or that
replaces people,
speech and facial expressions
and identities creates
fake proof of actions or
speech that actually never happened,
right?
So individuals today are highly
motivated to subvert the truth,
that massive scale specially for political
ends and new technologies will make
it easier to spread lies and undermine
trust. So over the next decade,
what else could be faked
via new technologies?
So if this is the risk
zone you're scanning for,
what questions should you be asking?
First,
what type of data do users expect
you to accurately share, measure,
or collect too?
How could bad actors use your tech
to subvert or attack the truth?
Um, what could become the equivalent of
fake news or deep fakes on your platform?
How could someone use your technology to
undermine trust and social institutions?
And lastly,
if you can imagine the form
that that misinformation
might take on your platform,
even if your tech is a political,
how could it be politicized in some
way to destabilize a government,
a community of regime, etc. So
this is just again, checklist,
thinking about your product,
questions to ask and risk zone number one
risk. So number to addiction
in the dopamine economy.
So in this risk zone,
we all have sort of come to
understand that time spent online,
maximizes profits over wellbeing.
And you can see that in things like
research by common sense media,
which shows that actually now the average
teenager spends nine hours a day using
some form of social media.
Uh,
and actually at the same time,
studies show that people achieve their
maximum intended use of an APP like
Instagram or snapchat after 11 minutes.
Okay.
And actually after 11 minutes,
overall happiness decreases.
So how can you actually design tools to
advocate for user happiness offline and
online over keeping eyes
glued to the screen? Right?
And so the questions in risk zone number
two that you probably would want to be
asking are,
does your business model you maximize
user attention and engagement?
You know, essentially the more the better.
And if so, is that good for people?
You know, what is extreme use look
like? Um, and how would you know,
moderate versus extreme use?
How could you design a system that
actually courages moderate use.
And lastly,
is there potential actually for negative
material for toxic material to actually
increase and drive levels of engagement
that maximize time spent on the platform
for questions to ask around
addiction and the dopamine come, Hey,
I'm going to roll through these
a little more quickly now, um,
for each of these just so that I can
enjoy all of the eight risk zones. Uh,
so economic and asset,
right where new technology
can democratize access,
but it can obviously also
exacerbate inequality. Uh,
in this world you can get
cheaper insurance by being white,
right?
And 2017,
Oxfam international show that eight
people owned as much wealth as the entire
bottom half of the world's
population, right? So wealth,
concentration and distribution
is an issue. And this, uh,
new technology can provide income,
opportunity, and balanced distribution,
but it all can also cater only to high
income groups and eliminate low income
jobs.
So what questions should view asking
which groups are disproportionately
impacted?
Um,
how might workers be impacted on your
platform by virtue of the type of form a
or contract that they are given
contractors versus full time employees?
How might a communities with
fewer resources actually
not be able to access your
platform or B, have too much
access to your platform, right?
To think about how distribution of wealth
is impacting both the haves and the
have nots. Uh, in risk don't four,
we're looking at machine ethics and
Algorithmic bias, right? So in this world,
human biases amplified through artificial
intelligence as in the case recently
where Amazon's scrapped it's uh,
HR recruiting tool that actually said
if you had the word woman appearing
anywhere on your resume,
you were actually,
I think it was 27 times less likely to
receive an interview then if that were,
did not appear as a keyword on the resume,
the AI trained itself.
But actually, um, you know,
the application of AI in critical
domains like welfare and education,
employment and criminal justice,
criminal justice has intensified, right?
So the idea that technology is neutral
and that this is not a product of human
action is no longer really acceptable
because we actually sort of know that
human decisions are being
used to make the models,
human decisions are using to categorize
the data. Human decisions are being used,
um,
and the algorithm,
and you can't blame the
algorithm any longer.
So at the core of the questions you
want to be asking are, you know,
do use deep data and machine learning
and are there gaps in the data that
historical biases might actually be
biasing the technology. So for example,
the compass criminal justice
profiling system, uh,
was sentencing black,
um,
defendants far more frequently than
white defendants and to much more severe
sentences because it was using
a dataset that showed, um,
you know,
that black defendants were more likely
to commit crimes again in the future.
Well,
it turns out that if you're using
historical data about crime and it's
incidents, right, and you're
using that to predict future,
you're actually just reinforcing the
bias of what has happened historically as
opposed to countering that bias.
Um,
by understanding that actually pass
is not a future. Does that make sense?
Right. Um, like black defendants, yes,
have typically had higher recidivism
rates because of historical,
deeply entrenched economic
and sociopolitical, uh,
inequality.
Right?
But if you use that to predict the
future and sentence people accordingly,
you're just reinforcing that bias.
Uh,
have you seen instances of that bias
actually entered your products algorithms?
Is it actually amplifying that
bias and who's responsible for it?
Do you have a diverse team that can spot
those risks early enough to understand
that you may be perpetuating those biases?
And actually,
how will you push back against the blind
preference for AI develops systems?
And do you have transparency into that
system and is their actual recourse for
people who feel like they've been
negatively impacted? In Rick's zone five,
we've got a surveillance state,
uh,
set of issues where surveillance tools
and facial recognition right today are
empowering the powerful at
the expense of the powerless.
So recent examples of social bots being
co opted by governments and militaries
for use and attacking their opposition.
Uh,
armies of automated software
driven profiles are used
to target journalists and
activists and citizens using
Western surveillance tools. Uh,
so in this risk zone you need
to be asking about your product.
How might a government or military body
use this technology to increase their
capacity?
So surveil their citizens who besides
the government and the military might
actually have access to those tools and
want to increase the surveillance of its
citizens as well. Who would they
track? And why are you creating data,
right?
That actually could follow
people throughout their
lifetimes and actually will
the data your tech is generating have
longterm consequences for the freedom of
reputation of those individuals.
And who would you not want to use your
data to surveil and what can you do to
proactively protect that data from being
accessible to those malicious actors
who might not want to have access to it?
And risk zone six,
we're talking about data control and
monetization where users actually lack the
control to share and monetize and benefit
from their data alongside the tech
companies that create and use it,
right?
So we've seen this actually
and we understand that
users expect access to tools
now for acquiring,
sharing,
interpreting and verifying or information
that's been collected about them.
And we expect,
uh,
that there will be an increasing level
of agency around data from users in the
future.
So if you're creating a product that
collects data and that's just about every
product these days, what are the
questions you want to be asking?
What date are you actually collecting?
Do you need to collect it or
would you just like to collect it?
Are you selling it?
And if you're selling it to who and how
might they go about using it to your
users, have the right to access
the data you're collecting on them.
And could you build a way into your
platform or product to give them the right
to capture,
share,
monetize their data independently
outside from you? Uh,
what could bad actors do with this
data if they had access to it?
What could the government do with the
data if they were granted access to it?
These are actually questions that
we've seen come along on the landscape
recently.
Um,
particularly with access to people's
phones or other types of requests from the
government for people's data.
And Risto seven,
we're talking about implicit trust in
user understanding where the misuse of
data as a serious problem actually
because users don't trust companies
with a opaque terms of service.
And uh,
the inability for users to
actually understand how a
popular APP or platform is
working, how their engagement
is optimized, what's being
tracked and collected.
It's really hard for users to have clarity
on what are the terms and companies
can expect backlash actually from product,
from the users of their products and from
employees actually when those terms of
service are violated as in
the case here with Uber. Uh,
so the questions to ask,
does the technology you're building
have a clear code of rights and are your
terms of service easy to read,
access and understand, uh,
is there a version of your product that's
available to users if they don't want
to sign the user agreement?
And could you imagine building
a product that would do that?
Does your technology actually do
anything you don't even know about?
It's hard to imagine, but this is
actually the case. And actually,
um,
if users object to the idea of
their actions being monetized,
is it possible to create a sustainable
model that builds trust with them and are
all users treated equally?
Um,
so could you handle consumer demands are
government regulations that require all
users to be treated equally
or at least transparently. Um,
could your product or platform
actually do that? And lastly,
rezoned eight hateful in criminal actors,
uh,
where online tools enabled glo
global dissemination of terrorism,
hate bullying, radicalization trolling,
doxing, and much more. You know,
we saw this very unfortunately
most recently with the
massacre in New Zealand or
social media platforms were
used to disseminate terrorist
activities and used to
radicalize the shooter in the first place.
So using platforms to actually perpetuate
these kinds of behaviors globally.
Uh,
and there is a responsibility as a
foresight tool to be thinking about those
possibilities before they happen.
So how could someone use your technology
to bully, stalk, or harass people?
You know,
what kinds of ransomware theft,
financial crimes or fraud could
come around by use of your platform?
Do you as a technology maker have an
ethical responsibility to make it for bad
actors, to act, to make it harder for
bad actors to act on your platform?
How could organize hate groups? Use your
technology to spread hate or recruit,
uh, others. And lastly,
what are the risks of your
technology being weaponized?
And what responsibility
do you have to prevent it?
So if you go through those eight risks
zones and there's a lot more embedded in
each of them, you can download this full
full toolkit from ethical o s. Dot. Org.
Uh, there's a lot more embedded
in each of those risks zones.
But if you go through that,
here's three things to do. Uh,
share it with your team. Go through
this as an exercise with your team.
Go through the risks zones,
understand the impact of your
technology at your team level. Um,
you could consider adding some of
those top questions to your product
requirements document or
any other document that you
set out at the beginning of
the development cycle to think about,
which was questions you should be
asking all along the way as you develop.
And before you ship.
And lastly,
you should scan the horizon actually on
as an ongoing exercise for additional
information about the risks zones.
And if you're doing that,
you're doing the work of the ethical ols
and thinking about the consequences of
the tech before you ship.
The last tool we built
unethical ols is actually, um,
just some ideas for how to do some
alternative ways of future proofing.
So thinking about best practices that
could help the tech community community
mitigate risk at scale.
So these are some ideas for industry
wide efforts to create products that you
know, have a company in
humanity's best interest in mind.
So these are just kind
of pie in the sky ideas.
There's a lot more actually
in the ethical OSMP
but here are a few to consider.
Um, so one is, you know,
a hippocratic oath for data workers.
So you could imagine a world where
anyone working with data took an oath to
protect the data of its users. So if
you were going to develop such a thing,
what commitments would it include?
Uh,
what rituals would be associated with
taking the oath in the first place.
It's actually a beautiful ceremony for
civil engineers in Canada called the
order of the iron ring. And when you
become a civil engineer in Canada,
you're presented a ring that
is apocryphally made from
the metal of a collapsed
bridge and you're meant to wear
the ring on your right hand.
You're drafting hand.
So that all along the way through
your work as a civil engineer,
you keep in mind the ethical
responsibility to the
people who will be crossing
your bridges are living in your buildings.
And so you can imagine building rituals
like this for a hippocratic oath for
data scientists or data
workers more generally. Um,
second tech companies
have bounties for bugs.
If you find a bug for Microsoft,
they will pay you to have found that bug.
Could you imagine actually building
ethical bounties as well for identifying
risks in these risk zones or any others?
Um,
how would somebody claimed that bounty?
What, what should they be paid? Um,
and actually who in the company would be
responsible for assessing whether that
risk identified was actually a risk
than needed to be mitigated in the first
place.
You could imagine also a
list for employees within
a company of red flags that
absolutely required running up the
flagpole or pulling the metaphorical red
handle. Um, so what could go on that list?
Who would create an update it and
would it be shared across the company?
Would it be public? Would
it be proprietary? What each
company have it, you know,
these are questions to think about
as we think about resilience building
actually has a system of companies and
product makers and developers, et cetera.
And the last idea we had
was just, um, you know,
creating an actual licensure for
technologists. So, you know, you could,
as lawyers and doctors and a whole bunch
of other professions have licensed to
operate and actually if
you behave unethically,
you can be stripped of that license
and no longer be able to access the
privileges of that profession.
Could you develop a similar thing for
technologists? Um, and if you did,
what kinds of things would actually
cause you to lose a license, right?
Medical malpractices medical malpractice
causes you to lose a license if you're
a doctor, what would cause you to
lose your license as a technologist?
So all of this to wrap up is,
uh,
a way of thinking about what's
hot and what's not in ethics.
Um, with credit to my friend Jake
Metcalf for this, for this list. Um,
so what's hot, show us your work. Uh,
show us how you got to this decision with
transparency and what's not as follow
our principles blindly,
right?
What's hot is global adaptability and
interoperability of platforms as opposed
to adherence to western Canon only as
thinking about ethics and instead of
thinking about western Canon of ethics,
thinking about societal
impact more broadly,
what's hot is defining the due diligence,
that process of discernment,
the process of thinking through those
consequences first, second and third,
order what's not as an
inflexible framework that
doesn't allow you to spot those
risks in the first place. Uh,
not hot as close community.
Thinking about these things in silos.
What is hot is open source,
open dialogue tools that enable
us all to get better at this.
And the first place, uh,
hot ethics is a process. Um,
it is actually labor. It requires
sustained effort to identify, track,
mitigate and improve the consequences
for the things that we value as human
beings.
And it is not PR,
it actually matters because it impacts
people in their lives. And lastly,
what is hot is actually, you know, ethics
doing this work as assignable tasks,
right?
You can be the owner of this on your team.
It can be parceled out by a
product manager, by a team manager,
etc. With responsibilities for different
people to spot and bring these risks to
the table.
And what is not hot about doing this is
where ethics is a black hole expense,
uh, where there is no accountability
built into the framework. Uh,
finally one last thing. I'm going
to make a plug for a new podcast,
which if you haven't listened to it, you
should. It's hosted by Caterina fake,
who was the co founder of flicker and
has since become a venture capitalist.
She has a new podcast called
should this exist, which, uh,
I asked a lot of these same questions of
early stage entrepreneurs and inventors,
uh,
and startup founders where she brings
them on with a new product idea onto our
show and ask these questions.
Is the product of your building
fundamentally good for people?
What negative consequences and unintended
impacts might you imagine about this
product? How can you mitigate them? Have
you thought about all of these first,
second, third order consequences? So
that's at the core, the ethical ols.
It's a way of bringing foresight about
unintended consequences or unanticipated
consequences or consequences actually
that you probably could have foreseen if
you'd ask the right sets of questions
in the first place to the activity of
building something new and to the activity
of adding a feature to the activity
of building new code to the activity of
at fundamentally building things that we
imagine will be good for people.
But we might be not imagining the ways
that it might be bad as well to put that
glass half empty.
So with that,
I will, uh, take it to questions.
So thank you so much for coming.
This has been such an enlightening talk.
I noticed that you, it's this product
seems to generally be based for futures,
uh, events, our future occurrences.
Could you reapply these to current
companies now and kind of revamp this way,
their system's flowing now,
do you think?
Yeah,
I think absolutely.
I think at the core of these questions
are meant to identify negative impacts,
right?
And you could absolutely be asking the
same set of questions about a current
existing product.
How is it doing this now?
Are we building a product that
currently is being used in this way?
And how might we actually just mitigate
the current risks, not just, uh,
anticipate those future risks.
So I think it absolutely has application
for current products. And again,
most products,
uh,
living in the world today go
through multiple iterations.
There's very few products
that ship and are done.
And so with each iteration, with each
new feature, with each tweak to the code,
with each tweak to the platform as we go
through the evolution of a product too,
it's also a useful tool. Even along the
way there, I would say, uh, that it's not,
and this is not meant to
be a one and done activity.
It's not meant to just be asked
one time and then say, okay,
well we asked the set of questions and
now we don't have to worry about it.
But building that process of discernment
that all along the way we're asking
these questions with frequency,
uh,
that we're able to spot and great
if we answer no, nothing's changed.
And that risk that we anticipated has,
is no longer an issue and it continues
in long no longer be an issue.
But at the point at which
it becomes an issue, again,
let's surface it and let's think
about ways to change the behavior,
change the product,
changed the way we're doing business.
So do you know of any companies
that have already started this?
Anyone reported back to you saying,
yes,
we've had a week long meeting to
go through all of these steps.
We do know companies that are using this.
Uh,
and we have actually also had some
degree of success embedding this in
incubators and accelerators as well.
Uh,
so we're able to sort of get a class
of early stage founders are startups
thinking about these
issues from the outset. Um,
I can't speak specifically
about any particular companies.
A lot of companies don't necessarily want
to be public about their use of tools
like this.
I think that's becoming less the case
as more companies are embracing their
responsibility and their ethics. Uh,
as someone I heard recently said,
ethics is now the hottest
product in Silicon Valley. Um,
so I think a lot of people are actually
starting to be proud of their use of
tools like this and not shy
away from it. But yeah, it's,
this is definitely in process and if not
this other frameworks for having these
conversations,
right?
There's like a design agency in
Seattle called artefact group,
which design Taro cards of tech,
which is a card deck,
which actually asks a lot
of the same questions.
And so really just thinking about what
are the tools for asking these questions
and it doesn't need to be ethical.
Oh,
these questions could also just be
asked by any buddy on the team who's
empowered to do so. And
team leader, any manager,
anybody at any level should be
able to ask these questions. Um,
whether through ethical oh
or just because they care.
So ethics is not an exact science.
How do you decide what is termed ethical
and not ethical? Largely opinion. Yeah.
Yeah, I get that question a lot. Um,
so if it's not to use the term ethics,
I say do away with the term
ethics. Um, because at the core,
which I hope came through
in this presentation, when
we're talking about ethics,
I'm talking less about,
uh,
sort of structured and rigorous
frameworks for Western ethics, right?
Deontological versus consequentialist
versus utilitarian frameworks,
dissecting cons versus
mill. And really, right.
I don't find that exercise
particularly helpful actually.
I find the exercise of thinking about
ethics as this responsibility for
mitigating harm as the core activity of,
of,
of doing ethical thinking.
Right? So, um, in that case,
I think that that issue of
ethical relativism becomes
less of an issue because
really if we're asking these specific
questions who is negatively impacted by
the tech and you don't need
to care, you could say, right,
we know that some people are being
negatively impacted by this. And,
and we're okay with that. That's
fine. The only thing I think, uh,
I'm advocating through the use of a tool
like this is go through the process,
ask the questions, answer
them thoughtfully, discern
the potential outputs,
outcomes, impacts, and then say,
how do we trade off our values
against those potential futures?
And those values get to be defined by
you, by your team, by your company,
follow your values. Those don't
need to be defined by anyone else.
Those you get to define and
then make the tradeoffs.
Once you've asked the questions between
the impacts you might that might occur,
uh,
or the ways your tech is behaving or the
ways that users are using your product,
et cetera. And say, how does, how do we
square our values with those impacts?
Um, what, what comes next? I think, uh,
for Omidyar and beyond the Escalade,
this toolkit can,
do you have any comments about what
you guys have in the pipe? Yeah,
so I think at the core there's a,
a need more broadly for
ethical infrastructure,
if you will, that actually supports
this activity in the first place. Uh,
if you plant a healthy tree
in a withering orchard,
uh,
it's unlikely that that healthy tree will
resurrect all of the dead trees in the
orchard.
And it's unlikely that that a healthy
tree will flourish if the soil is
poisonous.
Right?
So building ethical infrastructure and
ethical culture is a necessary piece of
the puzzle that supports the use of a
thing like ethical Oh, assets scale.
Right? So I think one of the things we're
trying to puzzle through is how do you
actually build the kinds of things
that scaffold ethics all along the way,
right?
So you've got training of
future technologists and
how are they exposed to the
behaviors and mindsets of
asking these questions?
Actually all along the way as
they learn the activity of coding.
If they're computer
scientists or engineers,
how are employees onboarded and trained
once they enter a company to think
through these issues and then what kinds
of supports exist for them to raise red
flags. Are there chief ethics officers
are ethical ombudsmen that support that
activity.
How do venture capitalist funders,
institutional or otherwise set KPI's
and metrics for companies that actually
support their activity of doing ethics
better and having more mission aligned in
values driven companies in the first place
rather than just incentivizing growth
overall else.
Um,
what kinds of consumer awareness needs
to be built in order for consumers to
have more active voice in the
kinds of products they want to use?
How our employee voices harness on
the issues that employees care about.
We've seen a tremendous amount of employee
activism recently in companies large
and small about the kinds of
ethical issues that they see.
All of that speaks to kind of ethical
culture and ethical infrastructure.
And we're thinking about
that broad echo system.
So not just tools like ethical OSCP,
which is a really important piece.
And tools are absolutely necessary,
but also what is,
what are the supporting mechanisms
to enable that behavior?
Uh, just as a followup to that question
regarding the infrastructure needed. Um,
I guess like you're in the u s there's
probably a lot of skepticism with regard
to the ability of maybe like our federal
government to be able to provide that
sort of infrastructure.
So to what extent are you
optimistic regarding our
ability to actually put those
mechanisms in place?
And if that doesn't happen,
then to what extent are you optimistic
that the market or you know,
some other actors can do it in that,
in the absence of that,
I am not necessarily optimistic about our
government catching up. I mean, if you,
if you see the recent tech hearings,
uh,
unfortunately our members of Congress do
not demonstrate a extremely high level
of proficiency or fluency around products
and the way they are built in their
impacts on people.
Uh,
and yet we are seeing this
really interesting trend
of now some large companies
actually asking for regulation
of certain things. Now,
there are lots of reasons
they might be doing that. Uh,
but I think there is a growing awareness
that regulation will probably be
necessary and I am not bullish on the
idea that that will catch up very quickly
knowing.
So unfortunately the dysfunction of our
current government and the system of
passing legislation,
I think at the local level it's
actually probably more likely, um,
at the city and state level we might see
more interesting regulation coming out,
especially from California and a few
other places that are thinking about these
things. Um, if at the core
of your question is about,
so then to what degree will companies
regulate as it's called, right?
In order to do this better,
if the government can't actually assert
itself in terms of legislation and
regulation of these things? I think, um,
there is a competitive advantage to be
built from doing this particularly well
and building user trust
around security and data, uh,
about thinking responsibly about the
products that are built. Um, you know, I,
I often times come back to the example
in the automobile industry of Volvo,
uh, which created the safe,
the safest car on the road,
and every person who was going to put
their teenager into a car new to get them
a Volvo because it was destined to crash
at some point and you're just wanted to
protect your kid.
Right?
And so it was actually
competitive advantage to be
built around being the safest
car on the road. And
so I think that we, uh,
I am perhaps naively optimistic that
we may be moving in a direction for the
tech industry as well,
where there is a competitive advantage
to be built based on doing this. Well,
and in that case, I think that we may see
a race to the top before it. Um, again,
that might be naive,
but you asked me to my degree of optimism
and so I will say that I am naively
optimistic about it. Thank
you very much. You have for,
for coming today and speak and thank you
for your time and for taking all these
questions. Thanks for
having me. Appreciate it.